Speaker 1: All right.
I do have another story today of another one
of these anti-vax, unvaccinated people that
has died of COVID, but this one is particularly
insidious because of the details.
This is someone who wanted to get infected.
They wanted the immunity that they believed
getting infected with the virus would give
them, and they are now dead.
Hannah Hauschka, a Czech singer, is dead after
intentionally getting infected with COVID.
The BBC by Ben Tobias reporting on this.
A folk singer from the Czech Republic has
died after deliberately catching COVID.
Hannah Hauschka was 57 years old, was unvaccinated,
posted on social media that she was recovering
after testing positive and was dead.
Two days later, her son said she got infected
on purpose when he and his father had the
virus so she could get a recovery pass to
access certain venues.
The Czech Republic reported a record number
of COVID cases yesterday.
Mr Reck and his father, who are both fully
vaccinated, both caught COVID over Christmas.
But he said his mother decided not to stay
away from them, preferring instead to expose
herself.
He said she should have isolated for a week
because we tested positive, but she was with
us the whole time.
Proof of vaccination or recent infection from
the virus is required in the Czech Republic
to go to many venues, including movie theaters,
bars and cafes.
His mother was a member of one of the oldest
Czech folk groups, abstinence.
She had wanted to catch COVID, so there would
be fewer restrictions on her two days before
she died, she wrote on social media.
She was recovering quote.
Now there will be a theater, sauna, a concert
Sunday morning, the day she died, she said
she was feeling better and got dressed to
go for a walk.
Her back started hurting.
She went to lie down in her bedroom, her son
says.
In 10 minutes, it was all over.
She choked to death.
Although she was unvaccinated, John, her son
stressed his mother didn't believe in some
of the more bizarre conspiracy theories about
COVID vaccines.
Her philosophy was she was more OK with the
idea of catching it than getting vaccinated.
Not that we would get microchipped or anything
like that.
There was no point in trying to discuss the
issue with her as it would get too emotional.
Instead, he hoped that by telling his story,
he could convince others to get vaccinated.
That's the hope.
How scary is it that she felt good enough
to go for a walk and ten minutes later was
dead?
That is absolutely horrifying, and we talk
about sympathy.
You know, every one of these situations is
different.
But this is someone who not only refused to
get vaccinated but deliberately got sick.
She she deliberately exposed herself to the
virus, refused the best protection we have
against serious illness and death when we
have a highly effective and protective vaccine.
Where is this on the spectrum of sympathy?
I don't know.
And there is a case to be made that big picture.
The recovery passes are kind of a silly idea.
Now, if you test positive in another country
and you can't get back to the U.S. and because
you've tested positive, testing may not be
accurate for a long period of time.
In that situation, it makes sense to say I
believe this individual has recovered.
They should be allowed to go back to the U.S..
That makes sense to me.
If you have as a policy to go to indoor restaurants,
you got to be vaccinated or to go to movie
theaters, you've got to be vaccinated.
Vaccinated or recovery certificate doesn't
seem like a very good idea, particularly since
we don't really know that much, particularly
in the context of Akron.
For how long are you protected after recovery?
We just don't know the answers to those questions.
It seems problematic to me.
And so, you know, her whole goal here was
let me get sick to get better, to be recovered
to then be able to go places without being
vaccinated.
Even the pretext of that, even that as a pretext
does not seem logical to me.
But another tragic story.
Unvaccinated person says, I'm going to go
and get myself sick in order to recover and
have immunity.
It didn't work.
She is dead.
And we will have more on this on our Instagram.
You can find that at The David Pakman Show
on Instagram.
You can also find me there at David Pakman.